Salut ! Vidéo numéro 13 sur 32 de cette petite série de l'été
sur le fait de donner une énigme par jour.
Tous les jours je vous donne une énigme et je vous donne la réponse à l'énigme de la veille.
Donc si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier
allez la regarder puisque là je vais donner la réponse et la réponse elle tient en un seul mot !
Attention ! La solution à l'énigme d'hier était:
le silence
Le silence, quand on prononce son nom on le brise et forcément il meurt.
C'est la chose la plus fragile du monde le silence.
Mais vous, vous n'êtes pas fragile et c'est pour ça que vous allez tenter l'énigme d'aujourd'hui !
J'ai l'impression d'être Tibo InShape !
"Vous êtes les meilleurs !"
Énigme 13 avec accessoires.
Je vais vous dessiner un 9 en chiffre romain
et voici l'énigme:
En rajoutant un seul trait, vous devez transformer ce 9 en 6.
A l'aide d'un seul trait, sans rien effacer, vous devez transformer ce 9 en 6.
Comme d'habitude, si vous avez la bonne réponse ne la mettez pas dans les commentaires.
Mettez simplement "J'ai trouvé "
et mettez un pouce en l'air, pour nous faire comprendre que vous avez trouvé la réponse.
Passez un bel été, pensez à vous abonner avant de partir
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !